According to the Entertainment Software Association of Canada,...
...sales are up 25 percent mostly due to online purchases.
And that's already translating into more jobs for programmers and digital artists.
I mean in Nova Scotia, I believe there's upwards of 30 openings right now...
...in an industry that employs about 300 people.
In Quebec, there is about 2000 job openings right now...
...in an industry that employs 13,000 people.
And this is in the middle of what is the worst economic situation in 75 years.
The gaming industry has also had to adjust to remote work.
But, don't let the empty studio fool you.
This gaming company is among those hiring due to high sales.
We've brought on about 16 people.
And we're still in the hunt for another four or five.
The question post-pandemic,...
...will be whether people will continue spending so much time playing video games...
...when they can return to other activities.
People will have learned a behavior.
They will have been introduced to games, found an affinity for games...
...or the communities and the friends they they've made.